Remember our previous lesson about
making sure elements appear in the DOM
in a way that makes sense for
the tab order?
Well, what do you do when you have
content which isn't on screen yet, but
still needs to be in the DOM?
A good example of this is
a responsive drawer panel.
Now this is a really
common UI pattern and
it can present an interesting
challenge for accessibility.
To illustrate this, here is the desktop
version of that same site and
I want you to notice what
happens as I press the tab key.
Focus will start off
up here in the corner.
It will then move to this input,
this button, and
then it's just going to disappear.
Now, I'm still pressing the tab key,
in fact I pressed it a few times now,
but we're not seeing anything.
Wait, our focus just
appeared right down here.
So, what happened there?
Why did it disappear?
Well, you might see where
I'm going with this.
That whole time that
focus was off screen.
It was actually hiding inside of
this drawer panel going through and
focusing all of these individual links.
Well this isn't really
a great situation to be in,
and when you're building an application
you might occasionally find that
as you're tabbing around focus
seems to suddenly just disappear.
To figure out what's going on, you may
need to do a bit of detective work.
If you're tapping around and
you notice focus suddenly disappears,
you can go into your console and
log the document active element.
So I'll do that right now.
I'll start by focusing
my hamburger menu again.
I'll move through to the input button.
And once focus disappears,
I'll go down in my console and
log document active element.
Active element gives you a reference
to the currently focused item,
which in this case looks like
some kind of fancy button.
So you can go and look for our fancy
button here in our source code and
make sure that it's not focusable.
But another option to
do our detective work
is to use the chrome accessibility
Dev tools extension.
The Dev tools extension adds
a number of useful features,
including an inspector which will
show you the accessibility properties
of an element, as well as
a set of accessibility audits.
You can find these by
opening the Dev tools and
going to the Audits section,
located right here.
Here, I've unchecked everything except
for the Accessibility audit itself.
And I'm going to run it against
the present state of my page.
When I do this, you'll see that
it produces a number of errors.
Including items that are focusable,
but either invisible or
obscured by another element.
And looking at that list,
we can see our fancy button and
all of the other anchor tags
inside of that off screen menu.
To fix the drawer menu, one option would
be to set it to either display none or
visibility hidden using CSS
whenever it's off screen.
This will prevent focus from being
able to move into that element and
focusing any of the child
links inside of it.
And then when the element
comes back on screen, or
just before it's about
to animate on screen,
we can set it back to display:block or
set the visibility back to visible.
Now in the next section, we'll have
you do some sleuthing of your own
using these tools to find some off
screen content and then to fix it.